okay so welcome back everyone thank you
very much for showing up I hope some of
you had fun at IBM last night very
difficult to follow Peter I think so in
law drawing not so many people but I I'm
actually surprised so many people are
here just for me to get a get a feel for
is there any lawyer in the audience well
okay so I have to be careful what I say
okay anyone was a friend who was a
lawyer okay a good friend was a lawyer
[Laughter]
so my background I graduated from high
school in 2000 so I was familiar with
the y2k problem which I think is
somewhat similar to the AI problem in
the sense that I think it's not going to
be as bad as some people might think I
finished my legal studies here in Berlin
at home at university in 2008 I moved to
Frankfurt I finished my practical legal
education there in 2011 I finished my
PhD in capital markets law in 2012 and I
finished the machine learning course of
and ruing in in 2017
so that was me trying to make an effort
to get more familiar with the machine
learning community I hope it helps me to
try and make things more transparent for
you in terms of how the law works how it
relates to ethics and what that can mean
for you as a machine learning and data
science community so no lawyer
presentation without a disclaimer as I
am just a lawyer so please be gentle
probably there will be a lot of mistakes
maybe you don't agree with everything
that I say I hope that's okay so on
quick overview um the simple report when
you look at these three topics that I
grasped machine learning ethics and law
the way I set it up is if for me if you
look at machine learning what you guys
do it's what can you do right that's
what you are interested what can I do
ethics is about what should you do in
terms of which would you know what is
right and wrong well we'll come to the
later and the law is about what
you do May there being an operator of
what are you allowed to do and with
regulation and rules it's always good to
to bear in mind what you want to achieve
so the topics that we're talking about
in terms of what are we trying to
achieve is or the downside that we're
trying to avoid is from your perspective
probably it's mostly useless tools right
you care about whether your model works
or doesn't work as a lawyer I'm not
really interested in that one other than
if you're not successful you're not
going to pay me right what gets more
important than you come to data
protection is do you invade the privacy
of other people um do you discriminate
against people do you fabricate models
that allow the oppression of people and
then the ultimate that the big one do
you produce something that is going to
extinct it make us extinct and when
whenever you look at what you're trying
to achieve and what you're trying to
regulate it's always important to know
what level you are talking about because
I think if we're talking about things
that might lead to the extinction of
mankind we will be a little bit more
rigorous than if we talked about maybe
minor infractions on privacy now so
that's that's good to know the legal
framework for machine learning there is
there is no comprehensive legal
framework there is however there are a
lot of relevant legal concepts um the
most important one which I'm guessing
everyone is familiar with because I saw
a lot of the topics there and I heard a
lot of the talks is data protection and
privacy um but there's also for example
intellectual property Peter talked about
that so whatever you do do you copy
things do you not copy things is it okay
to do certain things is it okay to
develop things that can mimic stuff that
other people do there is something to be
aware of
there will be an aspect of consumer
protection right of you if you have a
model that faces a lot of people public
policy and therefore law is very
conscious of
acting what is perceived weak people and
consumers are considered weak as they
face companies so consumer protection
might be relevant for whatever you do we
have communications and media regulation
which I am saying I'm not really a tech
lawyer because a lot of that stuff I
don't really understand sometimes I have
the feeling most of us don't as lawyers
don't really understand that regulation
it makes a little bit difficult for the
people who are trying to operate based
on a regulation because you don't find
many people who know how to do it and
ultimately something you might care
about ultimately depending on where you
are in the in the food chain is
liability so lawyers we can be very
creative so even if we don't have a
specific rule governing what it is that
you do telling you you cannot do this or
you cannot do that
once you've caused harm we have a
certain toolkit where we can we can find
ways to still make you pay because we
also have abstract regulation about
generally if you cause harm and you're
culpable you might have to pay damages
um so the most important bit when you
talk about data science and machine
learning is GDP are everyone familiar
with GDP ah yeah no okay it's it's de
jure the general data protection
regulation it's an EU regulation that
means I don't know how many people are
from Europe or not the EU is not a
country Germany is a country but the EU
is a let's say community of European
countries that is for as lawyers
probably for you it's boring for us it's
a little bit exciting because it's a
supernatural body that has lawmaking
powers even though it's not a state in
and by itself so one of the - one of the
tools that they have our regulations
that means it's passed at you level it
becomes law immediately in every
European state that's part of the EU
so as the you we have the privilege of
having one framework for data protection
which allows you when you're in the EU
move around and be sure that the data
protection level is hopefully always the
same but that's hope hopefully because
even though it is a regulation that
directly applies everywhere every
European Member State has its own
national data protection law because the
e regulation allows for some adaptations
to be made in Germany that is the
Bundestag michaud's Gazette and then you
have you Commission which as a
regulatory body enforces GD P R so when
Google gets a fine that's the EU
Commission deciding whether that fine
will be imposed or not and for Germany
since we have 16 states and it's a state
matter we have 16 authorities that for
each state and force GDP are so if
you're in Berlin that's the billion
adulthoods by a factor if you're in
Bavaria
that's the lambdas that roads aren't and
each of these people they may talk to
each other but they don't necessarily
talk to each other through so each of
these institutions has its own
interpretation of what is important in
terms of data protection so it's it's
also good to know where you are and what
the guidance of your specific Authority
is in terms of what you do but if you
are for example curious I've made I've
I've included a few links at the end of
the presentation the Berlin Data
Protection Authority for example offers
a consultation period for startups where
you can actually talk to them about what
their understanding of the GDP Rs and
what you should do and what a good data
protection that your regulation is or
how you protect the data of data
subjects so the most important GDP our
principles um it's it's one of the
cornerstones of this is it's restricting
the use of personal data so the way this
regulation works is you may not process
personal data
unless you are allowed to so the default
rule is you may not process personal
data whenever you process personal data
you need some kind of justification
there's a catalog of justifications but
that also gives you and gives you an
understanding of how the people who pass
the regulation view the use of personal
data so the use of personal data is in
and by itself suspicious so you are kind
of in in in a position where you have to
justify what you are what you're doing
actively justifying what you are doing
um another principle is transparency so
a lot of the regulations in there are
you need to make transparent what it is
that you're doing why are you doing it
that way why are you doing it this way
why are you do using AWS why are using a
server here why are you sending the data
from here to there why did you do that
model that way so in terms of your
considerations on how do I protect the
data of my data subject that needs to be
transparent also your processes need to
be transparent what do you encrypt what
are you not encrypt why do you not
encrypt it do you crawl data where do
you crawl the data what kind of data is
it so usually I would assume that all of
you since you're smart people you you
may you have these thoughts so you think
about it well at least I hope if you
don't now is the time where you should
change that approach and one important
bit that's easier for lawyers and
probably for you is it's good to write
it down so when you've when you've set
together and you've thought about how do
we set up all this model how do we ship
data from here to there and how do we
protect it it makes a lot of sense to
write away take notes and if you have a
lawyer hand them to your lawyer and the
lawyer will produce some paper that
makes the regulator heaven security so
technically you should not have to
explain people that when you handle
sensitive data of data subjects you
should apply a certain level of security
whether that is you anonymize the data
that is easily accessible or whether
that means you encrypt data so wherever
you have a large day
Poole the presumption will be you need
to protect it or you need to anonymize
the data because if you cannot control
access to the data it becomes a risk for
everyone whose data is in their pool
another one is the autonomy of the data
subject so gdpr
awards a lot of rights to the individual
so each individual whose personal data
you handle theoretically may ask you
what kind of data you have how you are
using it and why you are using it and
may even ask you to stop using its
personal data so if you cannot delete
personal data in your data pool
you're already violating gdpr because
you need to empower that individual to
be in a position to say no you should
stop processing my data and that should
not mean that in 10 years you will have
figured out how to delete my details it
means what already when you set up your
process you need to think about how do I
handle these queries and often times it
also means you have to actively inform
the data subject that you are processing
data so that's on the website that's the
privacy notice or privacy notice where
on a website I tell you or your
communication data I will track you on
Google I will track you on Facebook that
is that is part of the autonomy of the
data subject where the data subject
should be aware of what you're doing no
one's reading that but in principle we
lawyers are happy when when something is
at least in paper and it's
responsibility and enforcement so one of
the major problems with data protection
in the past was the rules were pretty
much the same in principle as they are
today but they were not enforced so the
fines were maybe 1000 euros or 10,000
euros so every company just made the
calculation of saying well if we're data
protection compliant that will cost us
500 K and if we get caught not being
compliant it will cost us 5 K so we will
not be compliant and the regulators or
the
Omega's waited very long and what
happens when they wait very long and you
don't do it is sometimes they
overreacted a little bit and that is
part of what gdpr was a little bit tough
on people then then then probably
necessary since we are in Germany I
don't want to be super German dominant
but I think we have a Constitutional
Court that is that is um that has been
quite intelligent about privacy issues
and data protections so they have
developed a right to autonomy on your
data from our fundamental rights so in
Germany the act of informants analysis
among ie the right that I decide what
happens to the information about me
comes from human dignity itself which is
the most important fundamental right
there is it's untouchable the German
constitution its first article is human
dignity is untouchable and untouchable
means it's untouchable ie any law or
anything violates human dignity its per
se illegal you cannot change it even the
Contra German Constitution has a default
rule in the back where it says you can
change the Constitution you cannot
change article one so human dignity is
absolutely untouchable and this rest of
informative analysis Susumu flows from
human dignity so the German
Constitutional Court in in in a lot of
cases where they had to deal with it for
example
nobody's trying to censor you does it
work now okay
I haven't even come to the controversial
pants yet okay so how do we do that it
goes from the bottom upwards so they
they separated your neck stuff in four
months analysis you're going into three
parts and they are quite logical so they
say the individuals we see as more or
less you as an individual but part of
the crowd everything that you see so you
seeing me here is the part that is not
that sensitive because I'm in public
private sphere is your private life what
you do in your home what you do with
your family potentially your friends but
that depends on the view that you know
constitutional judges can also only
reflect the view of society so when they
pass that family was the close one maybe
you are closer with your friends in your
family you never know but theoretically
that part they're part is what we
consider private and the highest part is
intimate so those are your inner
thoughts your feelings and sex which
well since in Berlin I think that also
changes with society so I think sex used
to be more private in Berlin than it is
now if you look at clubs like behind but
theoretically for the Constitutional
Court judge 10 20 years ago sexual life
was something very very private so the
intimate sphere if you go back to human
dignity the intimate sphere is more or
less human dignity ie that means if you
handle that type of information that is
untouchable um so when you when you
handle data about feelings or thoughts
or when you start building models that
can deduct my feelings or thoughts from
publicly available data you are moving
upwards in that trajectory and you need
to be a lot more care
about about what you do at least from
the perspective of lawyers as or
regulators okay so now those were the
parts that I was more comfortable with
now we come to X um also a lot of people
I think don't think lawyers are ethical
I will tell you however that under
professional regulation we are supposed
to be ethical so legally we are ethical
so when I try to figure out as a lawyer
what our ethics right we lawyers we like
in that in that sense I think we're
close to to developers we do like
precision right we do like precise
definition so I think that's also part
of the problem that we lawyers have with
ethics when I try to look up what are
ethics I spent I think five hours but I
couldn't figure out what IX other than
this one which is basic notions of right
and wrong and this will conclude my talk
no no so as a lawyer I try to do I try
to do more so what I do is I go back to
law and as lawyers we we have we already
learn at law school is be careful when
you try to regulate morality and there
is there is a dispute in the legal
community about should you be should you
separate law from ethics or should you
distinguish law from ethics and I think
distinguish is more interesting because
they're not separate but they're not the
same also so I try to to draw up
differences that you see when you talk
about notions of right and wrong and
when you talk general notions of right
and wrong or basic notions of right and
wrong and when you talk about law which
which you see in in in in legal
documents so the application ethics
usually right and wrong applies to
everything right you can whatever you
want to talk about everyone will have a
view on whether that is right or wrong
at least if you ask them about it law in
Empire
usually has a limited scope of
application that is defined so if you
look at the German so the coda will tell
you I'm governing civil law
relationships between people ie your
contracts your capacity to enter into
contracts your Constitution will say
well I'm governing how Germany works as
the Federal Republic of Germany and
whereas ethics is just everywhere um the
creator of ethics is society right there
is no there is no Ethics Committee that
was set in place by the United Nations
that says this is what ethics are it's
everyone has an opinion of what ethics
ethics are and somehow a consensus is
built but it's really difficult to find
out what what are we considering is
right and whatever considering is wrong
whereas in law I know also the law will
tell me who passed that law who passed
that regulation I can even um but we'll
get to that and then later also a
difference is enforceability ethics are
usually enforced if they're not embodied
in law they're enforced by public
perception right if Microsoft is acting
not that I'm arguing they are but if
they were acting unethical the way to
punish them for acting unethical is they
will look bad you will tell the public
that they are acting unethical and maybe
that will hurt their bottom line but
again there is no ethics court where you
can say under the ethics rule they did
violate that so please punish them you
basically go to whatever you guys do
github or Twitter and you say Microsoft
screwed up and you hope that people will
send nasty messages to Microsoft until
they stop doing what they're doing and
if Microsoft is tough they can just sit
that one out or pay people not that I'm
arguing that they do that but they could
theoretically pay people to say no
Microsoft a super-awesome stop stop
stop harassing Microsoft whereas in law
we are quite proud of having courts
regulatory bodies rule of law where we
say no if you do this there's a specific
process like in code for punishing you
and that is that is how that works says
actual legal enforcement which is
regulated transparency with ethics is
really really low right so no one knows
I don't know what you think is right or
wrong I don't know what you think is
right or wrong I can look up what the
law is on contracts so that that
transparency is very high
also if Microsoft or let's go somewhere
if Google holds a service because people
thought it was wrong to offer that
service I don't know who the people were
who decided that that was wrong
I know it's society but everyone is in
the shadows in terms of saying this is
wrong you should not do this if I find
someone as a regulator that person knows
I was the guy who find them if I sue
Google Google knows who I am I sue them
if I pass a law at least in most somehow
functioning democracies I can look up
who passed that law who are the people
who voted in favor of the law what party
were they're from so I can figure that
out there's a lot of transparency in
there and the accountability accordingly
is higher right if if we made Google
stop a service and we were wrong
there's no one who's going to be
accountable for because we don't know
who it was right as society as a whole
we can say well we made a mistake but
there's not there's no real
accountability where as in law again I
know who these people are if you look at
the Bates in the United States for
example when you run for president as a
senator your opponent will pull up your
record of how you voted and will tell
you you voted against funding health
care you voted against I don't know
supporting refugees
you voted against paying veterans I know
what you did you are accountable for
what you do so now when you're trying to
figure out what what does what does what
do attics mean in in in in machine
learning or in data science one of the
things that I found and I thought that
that I have to quote that since I'm a
lawyer and there are laws actually so I
was happy I found laws there so these
three laws which I understand make no
sense but but that's why you see what
you would try to do right so you try to
come up with more specific charm of what
is right and wrong so if I have a robot
or if I have a system it doesn't have to
be a robot in terms of physically doing
something but if I have a model that
does something that impacts people I can
come up with a notion of saying well it
should not injure a human being and then
it becomes interesting whether it's in
action or action and then if you go to
the second law it's it should always
obey humans not itself unless that
violates the first law and it must
protect its own existence as long as
there does not violate the first two
laws and if you know the book or the
movie with Will Smith then it's very
easy to create dilemmas in in this
system which is something that is
inherent with trying to regulate how
people act with each other right so if I
say if if there are two human beings
fighting now the robot has a problem
right because if one person punches the
other one and I'm not intervening
through an action someone gets harmed
but if I intervene and harm the person
who's hitting the other person I'm
harming a human being so what do I do
did you tell me probably the the robot
explodes because it cannot compute that
so it's bad code probably you would say
so but it's difficult to regulate that
and I I think it's it's also good when
you think about
ethics to understand some of the some of
the dilemmas that you face otherwise so
we'll do some polling so who thinks that
the court of public opinion should be
bound by the notion of innocent until
proven guilty does everyone know what
innocent under proven guilty means yeah
you watch TV okay so who thinks that the
court of public opinion ie we as a
society when we condemn people should be
subject to the notion of innocent until
proven guilty by show of hands
okay everyone okay so are you familiar
with the story of Peter Cartman he was
our most famous weather guy oh sorry
yeah Peter yeah so he was accused of
let's call it sexual misconduct um and
it turned out later on at least for us
lawyers are like very simple he wasn't
convicted so he was innocent but it more
or less ruined his career so even before
that person was convicted it was
punished and even though the process
that we as a society have put in place
to determine whether he should be
punished or whether or not it was guilty
came back and said he was not guilty he
was subject in essence to very severe
punishment because I think even if he
had been convicted they would not have
been a fine as large as what he is
probably foregone in income by becoming
a persona non grata in society and in
that case even though you would say well
we should not have convicted him before
the court came back with a verdict he
was more or less convicted and that's my
point about accountability no one came
back and said we were really sorry
let's make you a famous person again and
and and hug you
so you feel you feel like so he is still
a very disliked person even though he
was not guilty part of that is because
some of the details of the way he treats
women came out and even though legally
that
was not considered illegal society I
think came to the conclusion that they
were wrong um but if you are that human
being it's it's quite frightening to
think that even though you know you have
not committed a crime or something
illegal people can put your life on
display for all of society to judge you
while sitting in the shadows
okay so then something that that has
been mentioned here before who thinks
that you should operate a bail
prediction system ie a system that
predicts whether or not people should be
let go on bail by posting money until
their court hearing who thinks you
should you should operate the system
that Dimmick that discriminate against
minorities ok very good you're passed
the test what if the system is more
accurate than judges or review bots on
overall accuracy no one who look at him
he that's there's a race system right
there no but but you see now you start
thinking in terms of what is right and
wrong if if I'm denying a lot of
innocent people potentially bail that's
also not the nice thing to do and now
I'm trying to figure out can I trade
overall people against minorities so now
what if the system is more accurate than
judges or review boards on both of our
accuracy and accuracy for minorities who
thinks you should operate a bail system
now an automated system everyone else
think the judges should send minorities
to jail even though they should go out
okay that's quite interesting because in
the legal community there is a tendency
to say no this is something that that
humans
should do because it affects human lives
whereas I would have expected here that
people say well if the accuracy is
better for an artist and why not why not
have it operated by a model okay okay so
those are some of the things that when
you when you deal with that the example
was something that they operated in the
United States where the system turned
out to be more rigorous on on for
example African Americans and then it
was on Caucasians indeed the the odd
thing about that story is that the
system was put in place with the
intention to be less racially biased
than white judges for example so the
idea I think had some merit to it to say
well if there are a lot of Caucasian
judges judging African Americans maybe
it's easier if we have a system that has
no racial background to to judge
everyone sounds fair on the face of it I
think they made technical mistakes which
is where you are better placed to
analyze what they did and then we as
lawyers are yeah so what did the you do
and what we always do is we appoint
expert groups so there's now an expert
group on artificial intelligence and
it's an independent body set up by the
European Commission to give you some
insights into lawmaking when a subject
is very very difficult what lawmakers
usually do is they step aside and they
say we'll have some experts tell us what
we should do that way people will not
blame us when they come back and say we
should do something and we can also if
we don't like it we can always say well
we're not going to do it or we're just
going to bury the report it has 52
members
it's tasked with two deliverables it was
supposed to draft AI Attucks guidelines
and a public investment public policy
and investment recommendation in terms
of putting Europe on the map on
artificial intelligence both were were
published already and they came up with
the idea that trustworthy AI is the
solution to all of the problems around
artificial intelligence so in AI we can
trust per se as n AI that doesn't cause
any problems and they came up with three
criteria which are very groundbreaking
so it should be lawful so your system
should comply with legal regulation it
should be ethical and it should be
robust
so it should work so that's if you if
you look at them the amount of time and
money you spend that's that's a little
bit of a disappointing outcome
potentially and they also carved out the
legal part and they dealt with ethics
mostly and some of the robustness so
when we look at what they came up in
terms of ethical principles they came to
the conclusion that they are rooted in
fundamental rights so we Germans sit
there and say yes our Constitutional
Court figured that one out also some
time ago and the four cornerstones that
they came up with were respect for human
autonomy prevention of harm fairness and
explica bility so if you remember what I
talked about when I talked about GDP are
some of the notions are already in GDP
are and the frustrating part here is
that they don't help you understand to
what extent does GDP are already achieve
these ethical goals and to what extent
do we need to do anything so where do we
go from here um there is there will be
some regulation that's coming there will
be something that's doing and it's
probably going to interfere with your
work and to make sure that this that
this really works that this works out in
the end I think there are three main
building blocks and it's it's a funny
coincidence that that there was an
open-source presentation before that
because I
think open-source is one of the most
important bits in terms of practice
because if everything that you do is
open-source and I don't just mean
software I also mean the way you talk
about what makes sense what doesn't make
sense if all of that is open-source per
se that makes it easier to argue to
regulate us that there's no reason to
come up with some guideline from some
experts telling everyone how to act but
rather that the community is finding
solutions to these problems because I
think you are best placed to solve these
problems because you understand what
you're doing me as a lawyer I don't
understand how your systems work so it's
really difficult for me to come up with
rules on how you should do that I'm a
huge fan of smart regulation so
economically of course stupid regulation
is more lucrative for me because it's
it's it's more difficult for you it so
it means you have to hire a lawyer but
but smart regulation is actually more
fun because you can you can help people
easier and smart regulation to me means
it grows organically ideally law grows
organically right so the process is
society comes together agrees on certain
rules and if there's enough consensus
that grows into a law so if you have
things where you as a community can
agree those are best practices the
natural way to develop regulation is
look at your best practices and try to
just tie them down into legally specific
language but not changing what it is
that you're doing rather understanding
would you as a community say makes sense
and putting that into law and I think
that leads to something that that is
maybe not happening enough it's
disciplines talking to each other it's
data scientists machine learning experts
talking to lawyers talking to ethical
experts and part of that is me making an
effort of being here and trying to find
out all all of these things work and
trying to bring that back to the legal
community and if if you find it in your
heart to talk to your lawyer friends or
to
talk to people like me about what you
think should be done then then I think
that will that will help a lot because
ultimately what I think you need to do
is take ownership of that process and
for me it was interesting to see that
you're really already doing that because
when I researched it you get the
impression you're not doing anything
you're just you know building some
Terminator thing that's going to kill us
all or publish all of our search history
but but it was interesting for me to see
how much effort you put in how much
thought you put into these topics and
that awareness is talking to people
about what you're doing letting them
know auditing there's an initiative
which I found very interesting trying to
figure out how do i trace whether my
model is racist or not or whether it
discriminates or not I listen to a very
interesting presentation about
encryption and there's also people
looking at rule books and if you
yourselves can come up with rule books I
think that's a good good thing because
what I will warn you about is you should
prevent lawmaker or establishment ADHD
ie we if we don't understand what you're
doing we will still regulate you as a
legal community so we have no problem
regulating stuff that we don't
understand we've done that in the past
so so if you if you want to help us how
you would make sense to tell us what
kind of regulation would be would be
good for you and that concludes my talk
thank you very much
[Music]
any questions hey thanks for your talk
I'm just wondering one thing you I
didn't really hear too much about it's
the topic of accountability in terms of
should the algorithm or machine or the
person that created irresponsible or
more rather is there any law making in
progress that is tackling this that's
actually a very controversial topic in
the legal community we have we have
various concepts of responsibility and
all of those are being discussed for
autonomous systems so for example in
contract we have the concept of an agent
if if you are my my counterparty in a
contract and you use an agent to perform
your duties you remain liable to me
although you can restrict your liability
for that person to a certain extent in
tort where we don't have a contractual
relationship you're only responsible if
that person is socially dependent on you
so if someone damages your house because
they have their house being rebuilt or
so if they use an independent contractor
they might not necessarily be liable for
that so that would be a concept of of
accountability where you use a different
autonomous system but you're not
accountable rather you're just your
accountability is limited to carefully
selecting the person and another concept
which is quite interesting it's children
so we also have a concept for parents
being accountable for children and in
the legal community there is a large
discussion ongoing about well what does
an autonomous system is a closer to an
agent is it closer to an independent
contractor is it closer to a minor that
is not yet grown-up there's also product
liability so if you develop a product
you're technically
responsible for what their product does
to people even if you did not write that
if if a common effector of manufactures
a car but you did not buy the car from
the manufacturer or you were the person
was run over by the car because the
brakes didn't work you can still sue the
car manufacturer on a product liability
because they put the product into the
market so what's most likely to happen
is that a I would fall into one of these
concepts where generally it's did you
did you follow best practice in
developing that model so if you if you
if you send out a model that doesn't
follow best practice there's there is a
likelihood that you might be responsible
over here it's not that question related
to tech but you asked us if we believe
in this innocent until proven guilty
concept and I'd like to ask you what
your view isn't that because I think
that when a person has been accused of
of something but by twenty five women
for sexual misconduct for example then
for a charge it should be valid he
should be innocent until proven guilty
but shouldn't that be enough of proof
for the society to Jessa to judge
someone if I think something that is
very interesting in and how that is
being handled is the National Football
League in the United States where they
repeatedly have incidents of domestic
violence and and they were trying to
regulate morality and came up with a lot
of them to to to answer your question
maybe even from the beginning I think
that notion should always apply um I
think that to me is maybe similar to a
model accuracy problem right where I say
I'd rather I'd rather take the problem
of not being able to condemn someone
even though in public I'm pretty sure he
did it because I don't like it the other
way around
where where I think it's too much of a
burden on everyone if you can be
convicted without being convicted and
then if you look at the NFL they try to
come up with concepts where they put
people on administrative leave so for
example if it's a professor at a
university I think if there's enough
merit then maybe that person should not
be should not be teaching per se but
maybe you should still receive a salary
right or if you have a priest with
little boys and that accusation has
merit maybe you don't want to leave him
alone with little boys anymore um but we
do have we do already have concepts for
that in law right so you can you can
petition the court even before they pass
the ultimate judgment to take interim
measures so for example restraining
orders would be an example but that's
before that person would be convicted
there might be an order saying you
cannot get close to these women anymore
and I think that that to me is is the
way it should be done thank you so much
for this great presentation it's time to
move to next one so oh yeah you have a
question maybe we are